russia's view of its invasion in ukraine
has found a ready audience in china the
government refuses to call russian
actions and invasion and state media
routinely echoes the official kremlin
term special military operation
comments on chinese social media too are
heavily censored in favor of russia
the result is a heavily one-sided view
of the war a majority of the world has
condemned here's more from fabian
krachma in beijing
vladimir putin he's a formula one driver
and an ice hockey champion how
formidable the caption reads
social media in china is filled with
videos like this idolizing the russian
president and in state media coverage of
the war almost exclusively shows
sympathy for moscow it's also emphasized
humanitarian aid that russia is said to
have distributed to ukraine
but very little focus on russian
aggression and the targeting of
civilians
the bias reporting has meant huge
support for putin's action among the
chinese people
the us has a lot of weapons in ukraine
and the weapons in ukraine are a threat
to russia russia wants to destroy their
military equipment i think it's the
right decision
my personal opinion it's the fault of
both sides but what fault exactly as an
ordinary person i cannot really
understand there's definitely some
opportunities that it opens up for china
clara tsao is with the atlantic
council's digital forensic research lab
and specializes in analyzing propaganda
and disinformation there's little doubt
that china backs russia but she says
this is more than just beijing siding
with an ally and as long as there is
destabilization in other regions you
know they have the opportunity to
really
expand their power and reach there is
definitely some opportunities that china
has with any kind of geopolitical
instability for its own motives part of
that is to shift blame to western
countries for the conflict it's also
aligned with one of moscow's key
objectives
of most relevance and importance is that
china
declared that it supports and it stands
firmly with russia in opposing
the continued eastward expansion of nato
analysts say beijing also wants to cool
sentiment domestically and prevent the
war from stirring emotions among people
despite china claiming to be neutral
over the crisis the widespread online
censorship is telling a different story
voices calling for peace or criticizing
russian president vladimir putin simply
get erased from chinese social media the
playbook china is using makes it
difficult to gauge people's views on
what's happening
but it could have serious negative
effects and even undermine international
efforts to resolve the crisis i think
ultimately to shield people from
the damaging consequences of war
and what is actually happening there on
the ground i think to create apathy in
war is is a really dangerous sentiment
it's going to lead to a more apathetic
generation of people in china for years
to come beijing has yet to refer to the
attack on ukraine as an invasion and
continues to call it a special military
operation and it says its relationship
with russia remains rock solid
and joining me now for more is marika
oldberg she's an expert in china's media
and digital policies and a senior fellow
in the asia program at the think tank
the german marshall fund marika why are
kremlin's talking points on ukraine
being reproduced in chinese state and
social media
um the line that the chinese state has
taken on the war in ukraine
is ultimately that the us and nato are
to blame
and that europe should you know maybe
seek cooperation with russia to to be
rearranged and security architecture in
europe
so this is also
why
chinese official media and chinese
official sources such as you know the
accounts of diplomats
are amplifying these messages coming out
of russia
and like on the one hand you have the
chinese government saying a court
conflict and confrontation are not in
anyone's interests and on the other hand
you have its state media repeating
russian claims about the war
therefore justifying it
why these two opposing strategies
so what i've called this what's
happening here is maximum pro-russian
neutrality so i think what the chinese
government is doing here is leave itself
a little out at the end
because there are some issues also from
the perspective of the chinese public in
terms of you know national sovereignty
which is something
that
the chinese government has put left
right and center in the past and very
clearly this is a problem about the
national sovereignty of ukraine
so it's actually you know there's some
some is facing some some criticism for
that as well but but the basic point
here is that the chinese state wants to
lend as much support as possible to
russia that it can afford
without completely committing itself to
this position so it basically wants to
remain sufficiently
ambiguous
that when things really really go
southwest for russia and things have not
been going well um based on all that we
know right
it can still somehow pull itself out and
say but look we've always we've never
supported russia we've always you know
also given humanitarian aid to ukraine
so really we we haven't been partial in
this conflict even even though they have
been
do you see this media coverage of the
ukraine war somehow setting a precedent
for how russia and china amplify each
other's messages in the future
there's been some amplification in the
past between the two
never super coordinated as far as i know
but definitely some coordination and
then opportunistic amplification
um i do think this is um
slightly more
slightly more
slightly stronger than what we've seen
in the past um it is definitely based on
the the shared assumption that you know
the west is in decline other countries
are on the rise so we might just get
away with this um we know with with
amplifying this and with um
with taking the russian side on this
i i do think um
even though this is an extreme example i
think we're gonna see more of this kind
of coordination and and mutual
amplification
maraca olberg we leave it there thank
you so much for joining us today